hello there reject nation i'm greg alba
hi I'm John Humphrey we are gonna do a
topper war tear video requests from
patreon top patron longtime subscriber
has his own channel we love this guy's
name is gene Jeter and he has a wide
variety of videos and usually his
request for the month or one of his
videos he has this challenge video I've
never heard of this challenge before it
sounds fascinating I'm glad he sent it
over it's called try not to be
fascinated Oh yovanna ventura edition
have you lost by finding the concept
fascinating yes I'm just gonna look at
this looking bored as [ __ ] the whole
time and I will win for 3 minutes he
said that she is a model and an
influencer gotta love influencers are
the most important people in the world
they influence individuals she focuses
on fitness health and animals ooh
Fitness for animals she was once known
for dating Justin Bieber and that is a
great reputation she has a channel
jovana Ventura 28,000 followers from her
thumbnails she is fully clothed than
each one I am excited to check this out
time to be completely disinterested yes
which would make for a great reaction
[Music]
I never thought I'd want to see this but
I mean it's interesting girl in a bikini
rubbing a pig on the beach you know I
admit it's hard not to wonder iswhat I
forgot what the challenge understand
this I will not be fascinated by the
concept now focus on how to not be
interested most meta challenge again
okay cuz then you realize how many
things there are to be fascinated by I
mean if I just didn't find you know
women attracted this it would be a lot
easier
well the thing yeah partly is well know
I know roughly how those things work so
those are less fascinated when she's
rubbing a pig I'm like what happened
here
you know yeah that's why I just want to
see your channel there's like it's it's
the concept like I mean I am so not
enjoying what's watching her I don't
know if I would say I'm fascinated but
I'm certainly surely I'm certainly
invested it's early paint I'm not
wandering is this her vlog this feels
like a Graham story or something
I feel like I wouldn't be just like no
what do I care
well if this was a try not to be like in
any way aroused or titillated challenged
I think it was always have it now
increasing heartbeat perhaps I must
admit it is interesting to wonder how
long it takes people actually learn to
do that you know well they will look up
what the word fascinating it isn't see
who is it done did we do it do we remain
unfair when we supposed to not be
fascinated by this black screen now hey
I'm just gonna go to my bedroom for a
few minutes oh yeah no I can handle the
video don't oh yeah I'm gonna I'll be
right back it was really fascinating I
have been fascinated by this before we
even films because the idea of turn out
to be fascinating just fascinated by
what the idea of the challenges don't
think too hard about everything that's
going on I could lie you know I could
just stay here with a like just repress
everything and be like all right but
what's what's play you know it's like I
try not to laugh don't laugh it's easy
it's an easy challenge it's easy to tell
if someone's laughing or not laughing
the tell-tale signs are simple but what
if I just stayed with like a blank face
it's like you know when you're around a
girl who's attractive or something and
you don't want to let on and let her
know that you think she's attractive so
you speak to her with no emotion yeah
say get away from me you're making me
feel this way this is your fault the
idea just the challenge itself it's
already interesting to me it's like
telling somebody not to think of an
elephant than the immediate thing you
think of as like telling somebody not
I feel like it creates its own weird
context by going try not to be
fascinated now immediately that's the
only thing you're gonna be able to do
it's a fascinating situation so when I
type into me what does fascinating like
we all know what fascinated means well
no were like the actual meaning is
strongly attracted and interested yeah I
say lost like pretty Maya pretty much
right away yeah I was very interested in
a few of the things ironically the
modeling stuff like the sexy stuff I was
like this is all pretty simple I
understand how this works I'm not very
fascinated but like belly rubbing a pig
or she's visiting sharks or like doing
other things like that
maybe we just want to know who like what
is this her vlogs were she's like hot
model who you know wants to bring animal
wear honestly if I'm watching a pig
being or I'm having like a mixture of
emotions in that moment of oh yeah she's
very attractive - oh look at that big
feeling she is trying to carve a special
niche because I feel like sunshine sexy
is not you know a very popular and I
feel like you know sex is usually
relegated to the shadows and neon and
stuff but you know you can be completely
cheerful and also sexy I think maybe
that's what she's trying to fear but
it's her intent to bring because she
works the animals is it - is is this
video for example with the pig or the
what were the lord of those cold arcs
a little shark see who its appointed as
you're promoting her her modeling you
know her she's orchard by that broker
she or she like trying to bring
awareness to these animals who are
endangered or suffering or she just
doing both but most people who are gonna
click on that what's gonna be their main
takeaway you know but here's the thing
here's the thing is is that hotness is
is a really effective incentive to
getting people to do charitable things
and I've seen this happen even just like
on people's Instagram start like every
once in a while like you know an
attractive woman I know they'll have you
know like a story or something about
charitable things and sometimes it is
what hooks people is like all this
person I sure
they because of them they know I'm
donating and you get that dopamine
that's true you know all Instagram
models are the best self help mental
health it is really really weird it
takes like a like a very specific
mentality to have that level of fitness
to have like that kind of body whether
you're male or female but they are
usually backed up with a whole like
spiritual mental quote some like are
there people are there I'm not I'm not
saying there aren't I'm and genuinely
asking like are there people who see
like me if I was like okay hot girl she
has a quote that is like a motivational
like that you know I'm talking about oh
you know the guy everyone knows the
cliche then just post a smart quote from
someone else that'll make you look
really high it's magic our scanty
scantily clad beach photo with like a
dissertation on body positivity
sometimes not even is supposed to make
me go wow she's hot I think is that what
this video is well I like clearly I mean
extremely fascinating we failed because
this is I say of all this was for we
filmed this is nothing but fascination
altum Utley I am fascinated by that
position partly because it's one that I
probably in this lifetime will never be
in just to be a person who's like really
attractive who probably has a fan base
who probably is at least partly there
because they think you're so attractive
like I I don't blame anybody
half the viewers are here all the
females are here because of you Joe yes
my modeling shots all over our is all
your sexy looks man that's right
but it's gets get some endangered
animals get a cheetah in here have you
to roll your eyes at that if I was in
that position I guess I'm like well if
you've got a platform you're making
money and you're trying to espouse an
idea it's not the least problematic way
to do that I can make
by a long shot but one could also argue
that it doesn't matter even if it's them
let's say like majority of people who
view you know you vana for example in
this video which is the only thing they
really care about is like man she has a
great ass or something right but if one
person if you're able to change one
person like one candle in the darkness
who happens to tap the main takeaway be
about the page you look into the pigs of
sharks that you've made a difference I
think again it's not a one-to-one please
Ivana don't stop making videos on the
regular please I beg you
you are a wildlife foundation what do I
need to give you you know just open up a
direct line to your checking account and
then just every charity issue supports
gene this is a great challenge make more
of them who else can I challenge myself
to not be fascinated by or other
emotions health through I want the exact
opposite
try not to be confused really overweight
hillbilly just frickin chewing on
doughnuts and loading a shotgun for 30
minutes initially fascinating then I'll
be like I'm bored now oh yeah then I
will start being fascinating again once
you you know hillbilly PC yell at me in
the comments all right guys
Jean cheaters go check out his youtube
channel what can I say man you nailed it
and you knocked it out the park with
this one you're just one of a kind you
shine bright like a diamond and every
time you sent over video I'm just I
don't want to know what it is I just
want to see it
subscribe to jeans channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification will get
notified every time we have video I'll
check out your von aventuras youtube
channel where she vlogs something and
you can bet she is always in a suit and
tie checks out on patreon what we're
gonna go now we're gonna rig up a pig